I have been doing reviews of my
supporters decks for almost 2 years now.
And over that time, I've noticed some
patterns, some common stumbling blocks
that a lot of players tend to hit. This
isn't just the new players, either. I'm
sampling here from players who watch my
videos and like them enough to give me
money about it. And that's to say
nothing of the deck building mistakes I
occasionally catch myself making and
need to correct. Having just finished up
a deck review, which you can check out
on my second channel if you'd like, I
did the sort of normal thing you might
expect of me. I went back through every
single deck I've ever reviewed, looked
at what feedback I gave, and tallied up
the number of each general family of
critique I gave. And this video is that
the most common deck building mistakes I
see and a brief discussion of how to
avoid each of them. Number five, your
deck is unfocused on the macro level or
in terms of its goals. This is a piece
of feedback I've given seven times in my
reviews. And of these five mistakes,
this is the one I see most commonly with
newer players. There are lots of decks
that are built around some central
synergy pillar like life gain or plus1
plus1 counters or self-discard. And this
is a great place to start when you're
building an EDH deck. Where the issues
start to show up is when a player builds
a deck centered around a specific
element but doesn't have any sense of
direction for the rest of their deck.
What this usually means in practice is
that somebody has a whole bunch of
different payoffs for a particular
mechanic, but with these payoffs
shooting off in a variety of different
directions with no rhyme or reason. If
I'm building a landfall deck and looking
for payoffs, I can add cards that make
tokens, cards that buff my creatures,
cards to gain me life, cards to damage
opponents, cards that generate value,
cards that hinder opposing creatures,
and a whole bunch of other tasks that
are much more specific. It is totally
possible that I grab a couple clusters
of cards that end up working well
together. Maybe I pull together token
producing landfall cards along with
landfall cards that buff wide boards
plus a couple options for ramp value and
combat amplification sprinkled on top.
However, it's easy to imagine this going
wrong as well. Maybe I'm starting from
the place of tokens and buffs, but then
I add one or two damaging cards like
tunneling geoped. Suddenly, the clarity
of my game plan has been diluted a
little with incremental damage being
played alongside the big dramatic swings
of the token beatdown plan and taking up
a slot that could have helped that token
plan more. Now, let's say I add a card
like grazing glade heart. Well, life
gain can be nice for stabilizing a deck
that is slow or light on creatures, and
it can also be good paired with life
gain payoffs, but neither of these
things are going to be true about our
landfall beatdown deck. and adding life
gain just adds fluff that doesn't serve
our deck's goals. Ultimately, this
problem will typically be ironed out in
the process of tuning a deck and
figuring out exactly where it wants to
be going. A necessary lesson here is in
restraint, knowing when to exclude a
card, even when it theoretically has a
bit of synergy with what you're
building. Part of why this mistake is
especially common among newer players,
is because it often takes a bit of card
knowledge to know what might serve a
deck's interests more than the 18th
landfall card or the 13th life gain
payoff. If you're cruising through
Skyfall with a certain search term
related to your synergy family, it's
easy to just add endlessly until your
deck space has filled up. And this will
create a deck that does something. The
trick is learning to crank up the
specificity. Turning a soup of generic
payoffs into a deck that knows what it
is and where it is going. If this sounds
like something you struggle with, I made
two videos last year that both heavily
cover this topic. One about building
decks that win and the other covering
decks oriented around a creature type.
Those are in the description if you want
to check them out a bit later, but for
now, let's move on to number four. Your
deck is vulnerable to opposing hate.
I've said this about eight decks in my
reviews, and it's a classic one. Some
decks are a bit of a glass cannon. They
have the potential to be very powerful,
but can easily get kneecapped and do
nothing. There are other decks that
simply have vulnerable game plans in
some way or other due to having an
expensive commander or a game plan that
invests heavily into a particular
resource. Regardless of the reason,
decks whose game plans are fragile in
some way are common. And it's good to
mitigate a bit of that fragility if
doing so doesn't have too much of an
opportunity cost. The most popular
suggestion here is protection. But this
is where I need to get into a bit of an
awkward confession. I don't like
protection spells very much. I have a
Voltron deck that uses a bunch of
protection cards to decent effect, but
I've had multiple other protection heavy
decks that just felt kind of bad to
play. Protection feels great to have
when I'm ahead, but when I'm behind,
they're the most useless pieces of
garbage clogging up my hand that I can
possibly imagine. I will happily accept
that this is a me problem, but this is
also my YouTube video, so I'm going to
tell you a bunch of ways to increase a
deck's durability without adding
purpose-made protection spells. Firstly,
some protection spells are useful
outside of protecting a key creature
from removal. My favorite category of
which is counter spells. There are
certainly other examples of this,
though. Flicker spells like ghost way
can get a bunch of extra value off of
ETB creatures and protection from spells
are a form of evasion. There's also the
boot equipments that grant both a
protective keyword and haste. Speaking
of which, haste. The worst feeling is
having a creature eat dirt before it
could do anything at all. But if you
have a creature you want to attack with
or activate a tap ability of, giving it
haste through some means or other fully
prevents this. Though you might be
thinking, "But Alex, I'm a blue player.
I can't run Anger or Arena of Glory.
You're right about that. But what you
can run is lay line of anticipation or
Alchemist's Refuge. Saving your next
pivotal setup plays for an opposing
endstep rather than trotting them out on
your main phase dramatically increases
the odds that you'll actually get to use
them and effectively increases the
amount of mana you get to spend
uninterrupted by opposing main phases.
This brings me to my final suggestion,
ramp. If you have cards that like to be
played together, but which costs a lot
of mana, you might be tempted to play
one and have it sit around naked out in
the cold for a whole turn cycle before
finally playing a card that synergizes
with it. By simply having more mana, you
can avoid this issue. And ramp also
works for bouncing back after a setback.
As long as you have cards in hand. If
you like this video so far, you should
smash that like button, eviscerate that
subscribe button, and obliterate your
current state of not giving me a few
dollars by signing up for my Patreon or
a YouTube membership. I made a supporter
only companion piece to this video that
covers some deck building mistakes I've
made this year and a preview for that
will be at the end of this video. With
that said, let's get to number three.
Your deck isn't proactive enough. I've
had this critique for 10 decks and it's
sort of related to the unfocused goals
issues in the sense that both are
concerned with a deck's ability to win
games. But the types of deck I have this
to say about are quite different from
those decks. When I say a deck isn't
proactive enough, I'm typically talking
about a deck that is already doing a
decent job of managing opposing decks in
some way or other. Maybe it's a
political or pillow for deck with tools
to keep opposing creatures away. Or
maybe it's a control deck with lots of
removal and counter spells. Regardless,
the issue here is usually that a deck is
spending too much space on this task and
fails to create its own game plan. The
most common place we see this is with go
decks, which if I'm being honest, is a
pair of two words that don't really
belong together. If you're adding a go
card to your deck, its effectiveness
will be inversely proportional to the
number of good cards already in your
deck. The first two or three go cards
might feel great for directing the heat
of opposing creatures, and maybe even
the fifth or sixth one as well,
depending on what you find yourself
playing against. Much past that, though,
and you're going to find yourself
drawing multiple of them, and maybe
there isn't a great thing to go in a
given moment. Sometimes opponents will
have a lot of great things to code, but
other times there might only be a single
key attacker with everything else being
an anemic little goober. And in that
case, you've been handed the decision of
either using a go card sub-optimally or
having it sit in hand doing nothing at
all. With goat in particular, I think
part of the issue is that players treat
go as a plan for winning in and of
itself when it's really not a mechanic
that can be relied upon to do that. It
can be a plan for softening opponents a
bit, but I prefer to play it safe and
treat go cards as defensive tools for
the early to midame that might
occasionally come with a bit of damage
and disruption as a side benefit. It's
easy to overload on something like go if
you consider it your plan. But pretend
cards are fogs instead and suddenly your
deck with 12 fogs in it is looking a
little suspect. This ties in with how a
deck is categorized. If you give an
effect like go its own category in a
deck building website like architect,
you're giving your brain the opportunity
to draw up huristics every time you look
at your deck. Even if your conscious
mind knows the limitations of a mechanic
like go, you might have lingering
subconscious bias that causes you to
feel overly comfortable in the state of
your deck looking at a category of seven
code cards. And this can be prevented by
simply categorizing cards based on what
role they're playing instead. In most
decks, I probably choose defense as the
primary task that God accomplishes. But
in my Malfagore deck, I have Carter in
removal as a primary category since a
big goal of removal in that deck is to
clear out blockers and buy me time
between Malfphagore ETBs. And that's
what Carter does. Notably though, I also
have Carter packaged in with my damaging
effects in a secondary category since he
can help with life total pressure as a
side benefit. Not the main benefit, but
a side benefit. This logic also applies
to a lesser extent with any other type
of deck that uses opposing tools to win.
Some theft commanders give players a
gentle nudge toward proactivity. Both
Admiral Beckett Brass and Ganty Kenny
Inquisitor require connecting with
opposing life totals to start thieving
in the first place. So, your commander
is already pushing you to have some sort
of plan on your own for winning. In
other cases though, players will make
theft the main plan and then they'll
simply assume that windcons will arrive
naturally. Surely my ganty will find me
a tasty card to destroy my opponents
with. And maybe that will happen, but
maybe it won't as well. Quite a lot of
ways to win the game are tied into
synergy packages in some form or other.
And whereas the tokens player has a
whole deck full of token generation for
their overrun effects to pump up, you're
over there putting up some meager
imitation of their plan with the small
handful of creatures you've managed to
scrge together. For this reason, I like
to play it safe with these as well.
There's a decent chance a theft card
will find you some removal or some ramp,
maybe even some draw as long as it's not
tied in deeply with a synergy package.
All three of these things are important,
and having a thing that probably gives
you access to some of them can be quite
helpful, but it's simply not a reliable
plan for closing out a game, and
internalizing that fact will cause you
to win more games. Number two, your deck
isn't reactive enough. I've mentioned
this for 13 decks, and this ties in
closely with the last problem. While
some decks overload on defensive or
control tools and fail to spend adequate
deck space on their own plan, other
decks do the opposite, underinvesting in
ways to deal with opposing game plans. A
natural question might be, what does
underinvesting in interaction look like?
And you might be expecting me to give
some magic number, possibly a large
magic number. And you wouldn't be that
unreasonable to assume such a thing.
Most of my decks feature 20 or more
pieces of interaction. But I've actually
reviewed a number of decks that feature
eight or seven or even five pieces of
interaction and where I'm okay with that
number. What these decks have in common
is that they are tight on space and
ruthlessly proactive. They have some
bold plan that requires a lot of deck
coordination to set up right and their
deck is all about making that plan a
problem for their opponents to deal
with. And that is a valid strategy. If
you have a Voltron adjacent deck that
can deliver a lot of beatd down in short
order, you might be able to snuff out a
potential problem player before they get
a bunch of value out of something you
might want to remove. If you have a deck
that creates a lot of life total
pressure for the table, you might be
able to get opponents to an
uncomfortably low life total before they
can develop super far, which makes
greedy value plays a much more
challenging task for them to pull off.
And obviously, if you have a deck that
can outright win relatively quickly,
there's all sorts of lategame nonsense
you won't need to remove. With this in
mind, the reason why I so frequently
recommend more interaction to people is
because their decks don't do any of what
I just mentioned. If you've built a
standard mid-rangey thing that wins on a
very average timeline, you need some
ways to slow down opposing plans or your
chances of winning go down
substantially. Variance exists, and
sometimes opponents will just happen to
put together their game plan better than
you can. If that game plan can be slowed
down, you're still in it. But without
interaction, you're out of things. Sure,
there might be times when you're the one
whom the variants gods favor, but
there's a good chance your opponents
will be ready for that with interaction
of their own. Notably, this trend of
slower decks needing more removal
continues all the way down and also has
implications for what type of
interaction works best. If you're a
faster mid-range deck, it might feel
good to run mostly mana efficient one
for one classics like Path to Exile,
Nature's Claim, and Bitter Triumph since
you might just need to cut down one or
two opposing threats to stay in the
driving seat of the game. On the other
hand, if you're playing a deck that's on
the slower end, there's a good chance
your game plan will need to be grindier
and care much more about card
efficiency. On the most generic end,
this could just be cards that remove
more stuff for more mana, but you can
also tie your interaction into your
deck's synergy packages for increased
efficiency. In my shroom deck, I run
mostly ETB based interaction with no
conventional instant or sorcery removal,
and this can allow the deck to outvalue
all three opponents at the same time
once it gets fully chugging with its
flicker engine. In this deck's case,
this lack of one for one interaction
feels okay since the slides can step in
as emergency creature removal in a
pinch. But for some decks, that
reduction in contingency removal could
be a counterbalancing force to improved
card forcard value. The big picture here
is that you shouldn't think about your
deck's interaction as some kind of grim
obligation you need to fulfill so a
YouTuber won't be disappointed in you.
Figure out what your interaction suite
is trying to accomplish for your deck
and treat it as a part of your deck
that's in a state of collaboration with
your proactive game plan. Number one,
your deck is unfocused on the micro
level. Or in other words, you have dead
cards. I have said this about 21
different decks and indeed running cards
that will frequently feel dead in hand
is a very common problem for EDH
players. That said, there are layers to
this one. The most pure version of this
relates to synergies that are relatively
thin. So, if you put a small life gain
theme or counters theme or tokens theme
into a deck, some payoff cards for those
things are going to feel kind of useless
unless they're good on their own or tie
into other parts of the deck. Sometimes
this might not even be intentional. God
Pharaoh's Gift is a fun engine card for
decks that like high-cost artifacts, but
without some combination of a high
creature count and ways to get cards
into the graveyard, the card's stronger
games likely won't make up for its
weaker games where it struggles to find
good exile targets. Another way dead
cards can come up is when we consider
amplifier cards and other cards whose
effect is based on how well a player is
currently doing. To be clear, these
aren't strictly bad, and they perform an
important purpose. They allow a deck to
turn a corner, a tool that leverages a
state of moderate power to create a
state of overwhelming power. A token
doubler might turn a modest token plan
into one that's a genuine threat. A
power matters card like Traverse the
Outlands can turn a single large
creature into a bunch of extra value.
And a damage amplifier like Fiery
Emancipation can turn a mildly
threatening ping plan into an outright
win in short order. The important thing
here is that these require something
else to already be happening and have no
effect in any situation where that's not
the case. The key thing to look for to
figure out whether these cards will be
vital game pieces or dead weight is to
see how consistently the thing you're
amplifying will be present and sticking
around. If it's a very common andor
resilient part of your game plan, that's
great. Pack some of these in. But if
it's a less common or more fragile part
of your game plan, you'll want to show a
bit of restraint. lower numbers of the
most pure amplifiers and more in the way
of flexible cards that help get a game
plan going in the first place. The exact
numbers will still vary persontoerson
depending on your preferred level of
swinginess and the amount you're okay
with stallouts, but this general
principle applies regardless. If you
want to hear more about dead cards, I
made a whole video about them earlier
this year, which will be linked in the
description. And for that exact reason,
I'm going to stop talking about them
now, which concludes this list. But if
you want to hear about some deck pulling
mistakes I've made this year, you can
sign up for my Patreon or a YouTube
membership, and a preview of that bonus
video begins right now. This has been a
fun deck to play around with a bit. But
the initial version of it had one big
flaw. It did not run any filtering that
dumps cards into the graveyard, instead
just including a high count of dragons.
Scanos also checks power on dragons in
graveyard, but my instinct was that
focusing too hard on that was a trap.
Like I figured I could play some mill
and put a focus on getting dragons into
the graveyard, but the hearty outlander
background still requires another
creature in play to do anything. So it'd
be best to just focus on getting a
dragon in play. And anyway, I should
have the mana available to play a dragon
on a turn I'm swinging with Scanos. And
if I also have one of my five Vidian
Joiner creatures in play, I immediately
get a burst of mana to make up for that
investment. There were multiple issues
with this logic. The first was in
assuming that a big dragon and Scanos
would swing at the same time. Something
tricky to guarantee with only two haste
enablers. Scanos is scary and my seven
drop dragons are scary. And while I do
sometimes get to swing for 29 with my
commander and a canopy gargantuan, much
more commonly I was swinging with Scanos
plus a smaller dragon and wanting to
hold up mana for protection or some
post-combat power shenanigans. In those
cases, whether or not one of my big
dragons was in the graveyard could mean
anywhere from 6 to 14 damage across
those two creatures and would also
impact